How many of you have been
bothered by mosquitoes
when you're outside, enjoying the barbecue
or visiting the local wetlands during summer?
What about that mosquito that buzzes
around your bedroom at night?
I'm going to leave youwith three tips
that can help you stop
the bite of mosquitoes
and the buzz of
mosquitoes thissummer.
First of all, don't create opportunities
for mosquitoes in your backyard.
Anything thattraps water after rainfall
will be a source of mosquitoes,
so tip out, cover up or remove these
water-holding containers in your backyard.
Clean your gutters and your drains,
reduce that standingwater that mosquitoes
love so much around our homes.
Secondly, insect repellents are a safe and
effective way to avoid mosquito bites.
Make sure you apply it as a nice, even coat
over all exposedareas of skin.
Unless you've got complete cover,
those mosquitoes will find a way
to find thatgap in your repellent and bite.
Lastly, we know that operating
a fan in a bedroom
can help reducethose mosquitoes that
come in and buzz around our ears at night.
It disperses the smells and thetemperatures
around that body that attracts them;
it might make it a bit harder for that
mossie to fly around and find us as well.